think about it Oh what interests me
about what I just heard and listen to
language and then go by just this moment
off wow this is so cool this is so
interesting just like what happened to
me when I took my first syntax course my
name is Martina vertical I'm a professor
of linguistics at UBC here you know
after high school I did not really know
what I wanted to do I thought I'd my
wanted to become an actress but that
didn't work out that didn't get accepted
to school and then I thought well I like
reading so let me do German literature
German philology and journalism in the
German philology I had to take one
course in linguistics and I took that
course in like that's what I want to do
so then I quit journalism and I
transferred into linguistics and then in
the second year I had my first syntax
course and that was it I thought this is
what I want to do for the rest of my
life you don't know anything about
linguistics you take language for
granted and once you actually start
thinking about how does it actually all
fit together and how is it possible that
we communicate like these complex
thoughts that we have it gets really
fascinating really fast and I get paid
to do that and I I get to inspire young
people to also be fascinated by that so
that's maybe really like
[Music]
you